well kirsten it's always nice to find
money you didn't expect for most of us
it's stuck
in our couch or maybe in our in our old
wallet but for the state
it's unexpected tax revenue today
governor steve siselak says nevada
actually has
600 million dollars more than projected
hector mejia has a breakdown on the
state's economic forum
from the new york in the last
14 months we've had to deal with covet
restrictions changing constantly the
governor said the sacrifices we've made
during that time gave way to this
increased
revenue projection governor steve
sisolak addressed the state virtually
from carson city saying nevada is in
better shape economically
with 586.2 million dollars
more to spend than initially projected
he also credits crisis management and
strategic decisions
over the summer the governor convened a
special session to close a 1.2 billion
dollar budget shortfall
which included depleting the state's
rainy day fund we're still a long way to
go as nevada tries to recover
as we move forward systelac urged
leaders to think about individual
families
yesterday's economic forum showed us
that those in our state who make the
most
were impacted the least and those who
make the least
were impacted the most we will not
recover
if we do not use these funds to build a
state that gives them every opportunity
to succeed
systelac said those opportunities should
include expanding child care
helping small businesses and investing
in community-based
services he said this is an opportunity
to rebuild
and change the state's huge reliance on
tourism
sysolac also gave an update on the
vaccine rollout saying as of today more
than 45 percent of eligible nevadans
have received at least one dose
and more than one-third of those who are
eligible in this state are now fully
vaccinated
in our newsroom hector mejia 8 news now